what is this he says emergency
and we're live okay we're officially
live folks um
this is an emergency podcast we're
holding for one specific reason because
tomorrow's podcast will be specifically
with chass palminteri the actor from
bronx tale which means we're not going
to have time to talk about politics
california and then we won't have
podcasts till next week
and i'm going to be on a special uh
event this friday you'll hear about it i
think you'll hear about it by probably
friday afternoon which i'll post it'll
be a surprise but we got tom zenner that
just flew in
he's here today he's flying back to
california no no i got airlifted here i
got rescued from california you got
rescued the uh the choppers picked me up
i was one of the last ones to get out of
california late last night
congratulations if we didn't do the
podcast tonight to talk about california
we wouldn't be able to talk about it
until next week so this is only going to
be a 45 minute podcast
for us to discuss three topics that
being one of them
general milly being another one
and they announce what's going on with
the tax numbers maybe we can get into
that a little bit deeper as well but
first let's talk about what just took
place with california kai if you want to
pull up the article
i'll read the story from the guardian
and then if you want to pull up the
article
before you get into it you want to
explain why this story means so much
from you you're from
california there's a lot because i'm
getting i'm getting bombarded but people
are asking me what do you think about
what happened what do you think about
what happened what do you think what
happened i'm like i can't send 100
messages to people what do you think
about what happened it's a lot easier to
just do one podcast go watch it here's
what we think what happened to
california so
governor governor newsom gavin newsom
will remain california governor after
handed handily defeating recall attempt
not even close to guardian right
newsome has prevailed in a historic
recollection that had him battling for
his political life in a referendum on
the governor's leadership uh
through the pandemic voters resoundingly
rejected the choice to replace him with
a trumpist republican i got to keep in
mind this is the guardian newsome's most
popular challenge was larry elder a
right-wing radio host who drew
comparisons to the former president and
who attempted to sow baseless doubts
about the election process newsom said
that in voting no on the republican led
recall california said yes to science
they said yes to vaccines they said yes
to women's rights they said yes to
immigrant rights they said yes to
minimum wage the environment our future
we rejected cynicism and bigotry and
chose hope and progress and then if you
saw him give the speech he got emotional
he said trump is claiming there was
voter fraud here this is a very
emotional moment for us he kind of felt
a little bit emotional didn't do any
questions he just walked off right
and by the way numbers wise yesterday
was 67 percent we know bakersfield and
fresno that are both big republican
counties they did not the vote comes in
a little bit later
now it's 63.9 percent
5.8.4 million people voted no on the
recall
3.297 million voted yes on the recall
you got 9.137 million and then there's
the stats on what it's looking like yes
versus the no so first person i'm going
to go to i have thoughts on this but i'm
going to go to you first okay i'm going
to go to you first i'm curious to know
folks if you're watching this
i don't know where your position is i
don't know if you're from california or
not i also want to hear from some of
your thoughts about what you think about
what happened with california but tom
you live in california we spoke
yesterday at four o'clock when i spoke
to tom yesterday tom couldn't even stay
focused for a second by the way he was
nervous the entire time me and mario
were talking to mr tom why do you look
so nervous he says today's the day
i said so what's going on i said
everywhere i go i'm hearing all this
stuff so why don't you tell us how you
feel about what happened last night
here's how i feel literally i mean i
felt this way last night i feel the felt
this way this morning when i was leaving
california too i i literally feel like
your favorite team say you've been
following a team forever and they lose
the super bowl but on that same day your
favorite team loses the nba championship
and the world series and the easter
bunny gets run over by a cement truck
why is that just because i had hope i
mean there's very little things that you
could hold out hope for right with the
grip that the democrats have and how
california has just literally turned
into a different state all right pat you
used to live there everybody else a lot
of people watching this right now either
live there or visit or it is not the
same state you take a drive anywhere and
you just think you're in an alternate
universe because this is not the
california that was the uh that beckoned
everybody from all over the world and
all over the united states that wanted
to be there so it was very depressing
and i literally i had built up my hopes
i literally thought there was a chance
that this could happen because everybody
i talked to that was a democrat or would
be a traditional california democrat
in a normal world
they're flipping here's the other thing
dash had baseball last night so he was
training from 6 30 to 8.
i voted
like at 7 30.
the lines were down the street at 7 30
but by 6 30 the la times everybody else
is calling this thing plus with all the
mail-in votes i'm not trying to say you
know that anything you know happened
that shouldn't have happened or there
was any fraud i don't know maybe there
was but how do you call an election that
quickly you do it because you have the
media right in your back pocket they'll
do whatever they want it's the la times
it's just it's unbelievable how they
were gearing up for this three or four
days in advance saying that it was going
to be a wipeout trying to get people not
to go to the polls
so it was depressing for me because i
liked larry elder i liked what he stood
for i think he made a couple mistakes
pat i don't think he got personal with
gavin newsom like he should have i think
he all he was talking about was uh
policy and what he was going to do he's
not an experienced politician he should
have got in there because he had plenty
of ammunition where he could have buried
knew some on some personal things just
like newsom did to him
so that's how i'm feeling today i'm a
little bit bummed but i'm an optimist
i'm always looking for the silver lining
and here's it for me we've got the super
bowl coming up in february we got the
world cup and we've got the olympics all
coming to la you cannot put on these
types of shows on the global stage and
have your your backyard be a garbage
dump which is basically what l.a it's a
very good southern california yeah
that's a very very good point you just
made yep so you so if those things are
coming to you
and they're talking about a shutdown
because of vaccine mandates you know
they just announced today bars movies
restaurants all the places you're going
in la you're required to show a
your vaccine passport to go into these
places they do that we'll just announce
today okay so how do you how do you run
those events well you know you you do
the facelift right you clean the
homeless off the street near inglewood
where the super bowl is going to be in
the new stadium or downtown or even if
you watch the sunday night game last
night they showed all the beauty shots
of la during the season opener for the
rams on sunday night but for the world
cup in the olympics it's going to be
different because that's the world
converging on your city and it's two and
a half or three weeks or even a month so
i don't know i mean i knew it was going
to come of course and then there's going
to be payback right because newsome's
going to take it personally that they
even tried to get him out so he's going
to he's going to bury us under his thumb
even worse
i'm scared
opinion on this or no you're some
question of course tell us what you guys
seem quiet because i'm listening to
tom's enter cry over here
all right bro how the hell would you
feel i don't know i mean i'm not from
california i've never dealt with a
recall like this i feel like this this
is a california thing how many other
states are having recalls your boy
george will who was a
uh would you say mentor what would you
say is that he's not a mentor i would
say he was a wonderful thought leader of
yours yeah he was one of the first ones
that influenced him you know he was on
uh bill maher recently last week and he
conservative right i don't know if i put
him as a conservative he's a hundred
percent a conservative but he's not a
trump conservative he's not a magazine
he's a not a maggot he's a bush he's a
lincoln project guy sure yeah okay
that's a conservative though but they're
concerned they don't know if it is to be
honest with you we can go off the rails
here i don't even know what a
conservative is at this point i don't
think it matters anything exactly i
don't even know what it means idea of
left and right of republican and
democrat of liberal and conservative
that they're just words at this point
well i do agree with you on that well we
have emerging are two very very clear
camps you have the collectivists and you
have the individualists you you have the
globalists and the federalists and that
that's what's really emerging that's a
better way of putting it i agree but i
don't think i i i would vent i would
venture to guess that 50 of the people
could not define any of those words he
just used yeah it's very collectivist
means what well so what is the bit we're
all going to do this
so so professor i heard a professor from
cornell university said what makes
capitalism work
and what makes this work in companies
and what backfires on companies is you
have to be able to pump up the
collective
but make sure you individually recognize
the individuals above and beyond
everybody else which means what the team
wins a championship you can say you
can't say oh we did this all together it
wasn't because of one person no here's
how a football game ends with gang great
job defense great job offense phenomenal
job but the game ball goes to
america's not doing game ball anymore
america is just doing we want we forgot
about the game ball that's what he's
saying collective but go ahead you're
going to make up not about california
look being from florida we don't have
the divisive politics you guys have in
california this is something i've
learned since being at valuetainment
even new jersey like gerard has very
strong feelings against uh
the don't say his name we're having it
again so to your boy phil murphy
whatever his name is very strong
feelings you have very strong feelings
uh against
gavin newsom in florida we're just like
look we're purple state
look we'll get along we'll not get along
it's fine it's all good i'll see you at
the club it's not that big of a deal
obviously in california it's a very big
deal but i'm not shocked by this i think
what i'm most shocked at is the fact
that i've been
spoon-fed this gavin newsom's out of
here for the last year and dude it
wasn't even close 67 it wasn't even
close
like we've been we've been whether it's
the topics we cover whether it's the
people that are on the show whether it's
who said he's going to be out
who said who has said he's going to be
out no just it's just been a theme that
we've been discussing that gavin newton
he's going to be out no matter what i
don't i mean well tom when tom center
guaranteed it i knew it was happening
no no i'm not i'm joking but continue
please the bottom line is this
it wasn't close
uh two to one margins is the exact same
margin to you what does that doesn't
mean anything california there's no no
you have to know that it has to mean
something that there's two to one
democrats in california california's
democratic state right nice try larry
elder wasn't happening the closest thing
they had to republican recently was the
governor screw your freedoms arnold
schwarzenegger yeah the point is this
i thought this would be a lot closer
because of the stuff that i'm hearing
around us but it wasn't even close had
it been 10 points
20 points whatever
it wasn't even a close situation before
gerard i'm trying to see if you're
trying to make a point bro like
tell me the point is it wasn't close i
know but what does that mean why did we
think it was going to be close no it's
not about okay so why isn't it close
tell me why it's not closed because
democrats
everything was voted around political
lines
would you not agree that that california
is not is the the most or if not the
biggest democratic state in the country
top five yeah blue estate okay some
would say number one so why are we
shell-shocked on this meaning why why
i'm not saying we why were you
shell-shocked well here obviously
because you spoke to some friends that
thought that oh god i lived there it's a
big it's not going to be like yeah
exactly but look here like you're like
oh my god the easter bunny got run over
it's like no
we all saw this coming yeah but when he
wasn't getting homeless
on every street around you and what la's
turned into you'd take it a little bit
more personally here's a quick fight
of what you asked
um adam right now is here's what it
tells me the democrats have a game plan
and an agenda when it comes to an
election they attack they rally they do
whatever it takes to win and they're
successful at it but obama was cutting
tv commercials all right biden was in
long beach on monday night they rallied
together whether they're telling you the
truth or not they have a message they
stick to it and they're ruthless and the
republicans don't play that way i
respect it yeah the republicans haven't
picked up that play card yet let me say
one thing and then i want to get george
thought here are the biggest issues in
california let me ask you let me ask a
question who from the republican side
showed up to california to help larry
elder not one damn person give me one
name show it up to california i can't
think of one
that's the point zero zero and larry
elder's so articulate because he's a
broadcaster that he can carry a message
by himself and he's likable and on paper
how could you not love the guy but no
one showed no one showed no one no one
showed up well that's on the republicans
i can't get mad at the democrats they
showed up i fully agree exactly
what did we talk about today you said
the best ability is your availability
yeah obama made himself available you
might have made himself available i
agree complimenters are available who
made themselves available no debate
that's why i'm not sure
here's what they said the biggest issues
were for the voting bloc first and
foremost not even close was covent 31
number two like you said homelessness 22
percent the economy taxes 16 percent top
three
wildfires in california a big deal 14
percent yeah and then number five crime
eight percent yeah and all reasons
i can't believe it turned out by the way
okay so to your point
they asked how's california doing with
covet
40 said it's getting better 40
30 said staying the same 24 said it's
getting worse so to your point they're
actually happy with the job he's doing
no no no no no no no no no that's not
wait a minute read that number again go
back how's he doing
no you said 40 said it's getting better
better 30 said what it's staying the
same and 20 said what it's getting worse
what's a bigger number 50 or 40.
staying the same staying the same and 20
is not a positive it's not getting worse
no no but you don't understand staying
the same is not a positive thing to vote
for
let me give my my take here well the
polling shows that he won so what are we
talking about not he won he destroyed
exactly this by the way this is like
this is like 48 to
you know to touch this weapon well buddy
it's not even close so here's a couple
things here's a couple things one
is anybody surprised
guys are texting me and the only answer
i'm giving is why are you surprised why
are you surprised tell me why you're
surprised okay
one on a recall does he have to debate
anybody no no
number two
can he use the government funds to help
him win the recall yes or no yes you
know how much money he spent of
taxpayers money to help them 200 million
80 million dollars that dinner cost him
80 million bucks
larry elder doesn't have that kind of
money which means what makes you think
the right guy won it's the guy with more
money and more pull one it's not the
right guy in every politics but let's
continue let's continue let's continue
let's continue second third part
there is no debate for me to sit against
this guy to really be able to weigh him
out so that's just not gonna be taking
place right i mean we all we covered a
little bit earlier but there's no debate
i didn't see
larry elder's policies going up against
his policies there was nothing like that
we did not see a single debate because
that's how the system is set up right
okay fine let's continue
what does this mean with obama biden all
of those guys showing up what does it
mean
hey republicans just so you know
that picture with you
bush obama everybody together
saying bush is now changing his legacy
because he keeps throwing trump under
the bus guess what you're indirectly
doing
you're doing exactly what they want you
to do for them to win because they are
united and they have somebody from the
other side on their side which means
republicans are confused if i'm a
republican and if i go out say i'm a big
governor republican i go out and i
support larry elder am i indirectly
being seen as being a pro-trump guy
because larry elder is a pro-trump guy
yes okay that's what i'm saying so yeah
so your advisor as a governor who's got
you know election coming up you're
sitting your advisor saying listen i'll
skip this one i probably wouldn't go to
this one if i were you just kind of stay
home dude you don't need to do this who
cares if california we don't get nothing
from california so i'm not going right
okay go to the next part so obama biden
those guys kamala go pelosi they all
support him fantastic phenomenal job
when is the last time california has a
republican uh governor when's the last
time
that's not a republican that's he was a
republican he's
he's a celebrity meaning he's a
celebrity that ran as a republican he's
not a republican he's not a republican
republican
that's what we talked about earlier the
words are so confusing just like i tell
you trump's not a republican trump to me
is an independent he's not a republican
the first independent president we ever
had was donald trump he's not a
republican don't get it twisted the guy
had to run as a republican ticket not an
independent ticket so arnold is probably
an independent he ran as a republican
ticket he's not a republican you don't
win as a republican okay just like uh
kevin that came over here meet kevin he
ran as a what democrat but he's not a
democrat he's probably an independent
but he can't win on an independent 51 49
democrat i say he's an independent but
strategically he made the right choice
to run as a democrat basically you're
saying people are independent you've got
to pick an rd the last time california
had a republican governor was probably
wilson or the armenian governor that
they have duke medjan i think that's his
last name pete duke that was an armenian
governor i went to a couple events uh in
his later years so so the last time they
had uh governor republican was quite
some time ago what does that mean for me
for california what are the chances
of a republican person winning in
california the next eight years let's
see let's process that together and kind
of go through it all right
number one
how many people
watch this year watch the angle i'm
going to take with this
how many people
like tom
didn't leave california because they
were hopeful that a larry elder or
somebody would flip the recall would
happen and they're not leaving
california because let's face it there's
not a state in america that has better
weather than california if you take
regulation the way that you handle covid
and taxes out there's not a state that
competes with california take governing
out if you take no no if you take
governing out i'm telling you right now
there's no weather and that's what comes
that's california
no weather comes florida's closed no no
no no i don't collect i don't think it's
they're two different climates
but i tell you i i choose i choose
california one i chose florida number
two just so you know but to me it's a
very close but i still put california at
the time and i'm not even living in
california yeah i'm in florida right now
but here's what just happened this is
the part why i don't think republicans
are gonna win there for a long time okay
four eight years i think it's got to get
very painful before something happens
here's my prediction
my prediction is
those who were on the tipping point
they officially booked their tickets
now booking their tickets could be 90
days could be six months could be two
months oh yeah yeah could be 18 months
could be 24 months but how many husbands
and wives
had a conversation last night saying
babe what are we doing i remember when i
had my conversation business owner i
left in 20 i left them what year i left
in uh kai
i love california
[ __ ] what is it like uh uh we came here
when february of 2021 so go back five
years as well 2016. we left february
first of 202 uh 2016 right do you know
when i know i was leaving california
2013 maybe i was in woodland hills in my
office a guy knocked on my door said i'm
here to collect taxes i said what he
said i'm here to collect taxes what kind
of taxes i pay my state taxes i pay my
federal taxes what do you he says it's
county taxes i said wait what are you
talking about he says yes county taxes
we hear that you're doing well we
obviously follow your stuff we hear
you're making money you have to pay your
accountability
i'm not even kidding with you this guy
comes and gives me his business card
like [ __ ] this is fraud yeah i go to
eighth floor my uh my uh what do you
call my accountant who were on that
floor i said what is this all about it
says [ __ ] they got you it's hit and miss
they barely get any business but when
they do got to pay up i have to pay this
is yet see you know it's nearly 80 000
this is that's two employees i can't say
you gotta pay that eighty thousand
dollars so i said okay i'm gonna move to
i'm gonna move to glendale because
there's thirteen counties that don't
have la what do you call it county taxes
burbank's one of them bourbon glendo
because of hollywood burbank was one of
them i think santa monica is one of
victorville's one of them anyways
valencia i think some of these guys are
one like 13 counties so i move
every time i moved more stuff was coming
up in 2012 i told morale and i told jen
brace for impact we're probably going to
end up in texas morale laughed at me
jennifer said babe i'm not going back to
texas and she's from texas
so we ended up in texas three years
later i'm telling you right now
god knows how many people booked their
ticket out yesterday yeah and i'll tell
you the only timeline is we don't know
when it could be 90 days it could be six
months it could be 24 months but it's
tens of thousands that believe in
capitalism that believe in freedom of
choice of choosing what i do with my
body okay and i'm not talking about the
abortion i'm talking about what i want
to do like nicki minaj type of freedom
it's people that just want to be left on
it's libertarians it's independent it's
republicans that are sitting there
saying can i really live with this for
another four to eight years and it's not
the fact that you can't live with
democrats that's not the issue there's
many states that are okay there's two
states maybe three states that are going
above and beyond four new york is one
it's probably a handful new york's one
the other one is what california so if
they thought like oh mass exodus
you just saw the people that are patient
who sat around that are saying you push
me a little bit too much that's what
they want too though you got to be very
clear they again i i keep saying these
are not stupid people in these positions
although gary newsom might actually be
stupid you can't
in all of the campaigning by the way joe
biden didn't campaign for himself
for presidency but he campaigns for
gavin newsom it's it's it's ass
because he didn't need to win california
in california yeah
and you said the right thing how many
republicans went out this is part of the
problem i have at the national
republican party rush limbaugh uh r.i.p
rush he has been saying this for four
years he's like somebody's got to get
out
somebody's got to get out there it's
like everybody in the state outside of
outside
he's too toxic
no again but that's what i'm saying
right there tom center what i'm saying
what i'm saying to you is the following
what i'm saying to you is the fact that
the only guy
that would show up yeah okay yeah only
guy that would show up well he doesn't
have anything to do right now so maybe
his schedule's pretty open uh i'm sorry
adam adam if you go back even when he
was president nobody traveled and worked
this way i agree with you on that yeah
and that's when he was president if you
ever wondered you would have never seen
this guy walking away from a press
conference
i agree he took the greatest
time i'm not even hating right now yeah
sure if there's anybody that'll sit down
with anyone it is trump hey here's what
i think the republicans are missing
right now a karl rove a strategist an
ass kicker that knows what he's doing no
no no remember when he was running the
show
there are there isn't you say the
republicans who are you talking i don't
know someone that could be gavin newsom
mitch mcconnell and and dick cheney and
the bush republicans team global
team global they like that the team's
winning team global right you have the
other side the the individuals the
business owners all that basket of
deplorables it pat said it best this is
people who just want to be left alone
fighting against people who refuse to
leave them alone that is the time that
we find ourselves in all right and
what's your tu what you just saw in
california first of all the biggest
thing that came out of this i had never
really paid attention to gavin
i was like this guy's got great hair
that's all i really thought but
he's basically
royalty
i didn't know he was pelosi's pseudo
nephew yes and he's barbara baxter's
nephew and that day he's married to a
feinstein well did you this is this is
the borgias did you also know this is
the winery you know where the funding
came from his winery the getty family to
get so getty
baxter
feinstein and and and pelosi so
marketable though this but this this is
what
it looks like
dude i keep thinking like 200 years from
now like i'm a huge history buff you
guys know that one of the one of my one
of the most interesting anecdotes of
history justinian what we call the
byzantine empire they didn't know it as
the byzantine empire back then it was
just known as rome they called it rome
it was always rome even though roman
fallen so justinian the emperor decided
no i'm gonna i'm gonna go and i'm gonna
get back western rome i'm gonna unite
the old empire and he he goes on this
campaign and he unites the empire right
but so many people that were not in
politics so many people that didn't care
on the day to day when the barbarians
after uh aleric and all those guys after
they took over rome and sacked rome they
called themselves emperors and they just
kept the roman policies they kept the
roman uh
the money so when justinian came across
and he would like go to the roman roman
people in northern italy be like
congratulations rome is together again
and he people would look at him and be
like uh
when were we not roman like they had no
idea let me ask you a question 300 years
he had no idea he's up for re-election
next year do you think there's enough
time and enough of strategy that the
republicans can put together to have any
hope for next november any okay so if
they do if they do who's going to come
and campaign for the guy
okay give me give me five so by the way
let me ask a question a different way
give me
ten names from the left that are willing
to go and campaign for anybody in any
estate for it to flip to be a blue state
give me ten names come on look how long
it'll take you go okay kamala you got um
pelosi if she can get on a plane obama
uh probably hillary
uh
bernie aoc
bernie aoc the michigan governor you
name anybody yeah
newsome anybody because they're that
united yeah i think they're united now
when they get 350 trillion dollars into
their unions and their power that entire
infrastructure bill
pay them 3.5 trillion they're only
they're only just getting started so so
but now well you were going somewhere
with this you're going to right your
follow-up is what republicans are going
to do that they're not going to do that
they don't have the money
mitch mcconnell this is this is a
problem the problem is
that one side is all about the
collective
the other side is all about the
individual this is why i believe center
right is the right place to be and the
only reason is center right is because
the right fiscally you cannot debate
capitalism i don't want to hear any
argument against capitalism i don't care
if you your feelings got hurt because
you're lost to somebody else because
they put in more effort than you did
capitalism works the only type of
capitalism that doesn't work is crony
capitalism and nobody wants crony
capitals except the people at the top
that are willing to buy that fine some
of them are doing that no problem and by
the way if you got rid of lobbyists a
lot of [ __ ] would change in capitalism
if you actually eliminated the concept
of lobbying a lot of things would change
but let me let me take a different angle
for you let me take a different angle
for you go back 12 months ago
uh 12 months no go back 13 months ago 14
months ago
who's a hero on tv every day this is the
cuomo's faucet
and newsom these guys were heroes okay
they were heroes if you thought about it
texas florida you guys are irresponsible
et cetera et cetera still doing that
with florida fast forward fast forward
to six months ago who became an enemy of
the left on the left who cuomo como yeah
how quickly did they take this guy from
the next potential president
to this guy's got to get the hell out of
here
he cut him off
as fast as they could you think he's the
first person that has stories like that
as fast as he said we're not shutting
down new york by the way he's a tie and
he talks with this
let me ask you a question who had a
worse story up into being a governor and
wanting to run for president bill
clinton or cuomo including no bill it's
not even close is it is it fair to say
it's not even close it's likely not it's
not even close okay so now watch this
now watch this
so let's put two people against each
other let's put three people against
each other you ready i love you let's
put a game let's put a guy named cuomo
in there andrew yeah let's put a guy
named newsome in there let's put a guy
named mansion in there yeah between
those three who is most likely willing
to say yes to anything their political
party tells them to do just to be able
to get a nicer fatter title i'd say
i agree
which one's the least like
i would actually tell you it's both of
them i would imagine
i actually think it's like mansion wins
by 52 to 48 but it's not a big
difference i don't see cuomo as a yes
guy nor do i see manchin as a yes guy
certainly not now the most angry as hell
the most marketable people on the left
are those that say yes newsom is a yes
guy cuomo is clearly not a no guy
he is a yes guy okay meaning newsome is
a yes guy they got a guy that they're
going to market fyi you may have just
seen your future president i think that
you have just so you know that here's
the question do you think he's more on
his
do you think he's obsessed listen all
you have to know
all you have to know is who's ma who's
better him or biden as a president him
him but naming one thing newsome's done
it doesn't matter
what did obama do
exactly what question did you just ask
gerard you're very intellectual i
understand what you're saying but you
can't you have to be able to name one
thing like wait wait wait wait wait he
looks the part what has what did obama
do one term guy he would yeah well he
was a great speaker i've heard gavin
newsom speak he's not obama okay then
he's a very very well put together good
looking yes he looks like hey that's why
he's the sexy voice i'm sorry he's
extremely marvelous he looks like
christian bale in american psychology
he's doing so much
that's why he was so worried because he
thought this would get the express train
off the rails as far as the only thing
that matters for him is to be
president jesus
john caso just gave 50 bucks he says
let's have adam live in new york city or
l.a for six months his position on many
things will change adam you're a smart
guy wake up bro no way
those votes count as legit even liberals
don't want their kids exposed to all the
trashy people on their city streets
anyways okay can i validate one point
you made though yeah when you had that
tipping point right as far as like for
me i think if you're not booking your
ticket out of california and you love
california you love la you're at least
considering what it's going to be
because it what is inevitable that would
pull the trigger and i know what it is
for me if homelessness comes into
manhattan beach
if that happens
i'll see you guys within a week let me
tell you this you asked about strategy
and this is the strategy right in any
particular situation all right you have
two binary options as your immediate
options you have fight or you have
flight and if you are not going to
commit to the fight if you are not going
to rally the troops and you are not
going to get a war chest together
get out of there
go to a place consolidate your
well-being this is why i keep telling
all my friends and family new york
philadelphia uh staten island long
island uh brooklyn
leaf let them have it they won give it
to them there's no reason that your life
should be ruined there's no reason that
the hours of your life should pay for
what they want come down to a place that
has your world view i'm gonna tell you
moving to florida was like guys in new
york
stay the hell in new york we don't want
you in florida and then what will happen
is let the weight of their programs
hollow them out let them die on the vine
and then go back and pick up the pieces
let they want to be detroit be detroit
they want to be moscow be moscow come
down live your life and then go back
here's
here's a
the level of strategy on one side is so
much better than the other side you know
how easy it is to be the team that's
divided just think about it this way
here's what you got to think about go to
the laker squad where it's kobe
it's shaq
it's malone it's payton
it's rod i mean go who was on that squad
everybody and their mothers was mush
parker everybody was on that squad but
you know what they were they were
divided they couldn't stand their
parents with each other
they were just absolute highest level of
hatred phil left it was so ugly nobody
could keep that team together right yeah
what happened to them did they win the
championship no on paper on paper if you
go take any video game you put that
squad together match them up against
anybody seven game series who beats them
nobody yeah nobody as a team team not as
you make your own team like michael
lebron you put everybody on the same
team the republicans have so much talent
right now they got a great squad but you
are not united you're not going to beat
anybody it's just that simple you're
just not going to beat everybody not in
california it doesn't matter it's it's
but but here's the other part let me
give you the other part that's what's
happening
uh
when when policies on your own political
side start making no sense
a kid will even question his own father
and mother
just like a part a individual will
question their own individual party if a
kid would how many times did you
question your mom or dad's decision
often okay
by the way
how many times do you think they're
going to question my decision as they
grow your kids yeah they'll still
probably of course they're going to of
course they're going to my son has
already done it tico's under multiple so
has dylan how long did you ground him no
he didn't get grounded i actually i
don't mind the conversations like that
but here's the point
the voters right now what is happening
is they're simply sitting there some of
them are saying listen man i don't mind
being a freaking democrat no i don't
mind being this but some of this [ __ ]
just doesn't make anything am i the only
one that's thinking this way some of
this stuff just doesn't make sense
that's when it gets weird because adam
as much as you're sitting here and
saying what you're saying
you wouldn't survive in california or
new york today you wouldn't be able to
do it you wouldn't be able to live i
live in florida but what i'm trying to
tell you is he's first hand
i lived there five and a half years ago
so i'm first hand but five and a half
years ago it's not the same california
today as it was five and a half years
ago six years ago so very different
california right if you go there today
then what it was five and a half years
ago people are feeling the pain now what
will happen with this part here what's
going to happen here this is what i'm
hoping this is what i'm hoping today i
was into rio sal romano
sal romano was the former mobs wall
street guy this guy embezzled they were
embezzling 10 billion per year not from
the stock market he had one point was
worth 300 million dollars romano for the
gambino family he did stuff with mickey
scars from the guy he did a bunch of
different things that this guy said
oh he did time yeah but sal romano was
he was literally sitting where adam is
sitting here right now he left about 30
minutes ago 45 minutes ago to be exact
30 minutes ago 45 minutes goes where he
left right and we're sitting there
having a conversation together
there comes a time where you can no
longer tolerate what's going on and
you're eventually going to flip so he's
sitting there telling the stories of
well you know eventually everybody flips
why does eventually everybody flip in
the mob world well because of this
because of that because of this okay
if
i back you up
and you continuously backstab me what am
i loyal to
so if i give you my vote and you're
constantly abusing my vote you don't
think certain parties are sitting there
saying why the hell am i voting this way
for the longest time blacks voted
republican martin luther king was a
registered republican
what happened when they were registered
republican shows up a guy named barry
goldwater right then what happens i'm
sorry it all flipped the parties flip by
the way not by a little bit yeah it went
from 60 percent to 92 percent of
african-americans voting democrat like
this how many how many african-american
grandmothers do you know that all they
talk about is the bible how many how
many friends did you have i had a bunch
of friends that was growing up all their
if i saw their mom or grandma everything
was about the bible bible bible bible
more than armenians whites or more than
any other it was always the bible that's
a conservative belief what happens
hey republicans you did this barry
goldwater no problem so
you know as much as i think california
is not going to flip for four to eight
years i think it's going to stay that
way i don't think this stays like that
for 20 years right i don't think this is
going to be like that for 20 years i
have a question no i have a rhetorical
question for the group here yeah this is
an interesting one so
there's no freebies in politics if you
do something you're getting rewarded or
you're gonna pay a price people don't do
things for politicians out of the
goodness of their heart every single
radio and television ad for gavin newsom
for the last two months was tagged that
it was presented by reed hastings the
money that reed hastings spent
ran the media campaign for gavin newsom
and it was mentioned at the end of every
spot where they accused uh
larry elder of being right of trump
being an anti-vaxxer reed hastings reed
hastings re-hastings
does that come back now because of this
this this race the streaming wars does
he get an advantage most people know who
has things that yeah i know he's the ceo
of netflix i don't think most people
know that he already has susan rice and
barack obama and michelle obama is bored
so i mean
look it is what it is here's here was
really honest to god looking at this my
biggest takeaway
san francisco runs the united states now
it's not new york it's not la it's not
even dc the whole united states runs
through silicon valley now and silicon
valley runs through san francisco
everything goes through san fran because
of the immediate social media
the politicians are are so in bed with
big tech and big tech is in san
francisco and you think about it you've
got gavin newsom dianne feinstein
barbara baxter you've got kamala harris
nancy pelosi all of them san francisco
residents right and you you're coming
out google facebook every tech company
in in america has their their hub their
their hub where now why does that scare
me because this is going to translate
into into general milli
who runs silicon valley
who who's running silicon valley right
now
do you think who has more say over what
google does
america dc or beijing
who dictates what facebook does today dc
or beijing
so
if silicon valley is now the power hub
the information center of america
okay
and silicon valley doesn't answer to dc
and answers to beijing who's running the
information in america unpack that why
are you saying that they all answer to
beijing you're saying all these big tech
companies are all answering to
actually ccp which which companies
they will change their
their their rules they will change what
they do which companies all of them if
you've been tracking this at all for
five years every single update that they
do every single thing that they do and
you're talking about hollywood we talk
about hollywood the southern part of the
state
john cena are they
they are they changing their movies to
make sure that they don't piss off
conservative americans or libertarian
americans or independent americans or
even democrats or are they changing
their movies are they actually changing
movies let's talk about this let's talk
about this with the remaining time we
don't have a lot of time together
because we got to head out i'll say
let's finish up at 5 55 because i'm not
meeting chad's till we up which has till
uh
uh 6 30. so
um
what's the solution okay brighter side
is what i want to do let's spend the
last 21 minutes talking about the
brighter side
so a few things some people are
listening to this they're from
california oh my gosh what do i do
whatever you're doing don't do anything
emotionally right now like you don't
need to do anything next 30 60 90 days
just kick it we're just having this
conversation because it just
happened yeah so you just need to have
the information you don't need to
emotionally want to all of a sudden say
oh here's what we're doing no
my suggestion number one start
researching non-stop
whatever you can get your hands on to
read research and by the way
any time we're having a podcast and
we're having an issue that we're going
to debate on the podcast i try to watch
two channels i'll go to msnbc cnn then
i'll go to fox on the same point i'll
hear what tucker has to say then i'll
hear what the left has to say whether
it's joe whether it's
you know maddow you know cooper i just
want to see what's being said on both
sides do your research don't just do
research from one side you will be
fooled i'm telling you right now you
will be fooled
if you just get your information from
one side okay so that's that second part
if you're in a state you know this whole
story about
uh you put a frog in the water you start
boiling it gradually he's not gonna jump
out and then all of a sudden he's like
it's too late it's 212 degrees you're
dead oh [ __ ] i died done right yeah
that's kind of what's happening in
california it's not a big deal it's not
a big deal it's not a big deal it's not
a big deal
andy grove i'ma keep saying this and
people say pat i don't think that's the
right way to live how are you going to
live a happy life like that
he has the best book he wrote on
business that every c-suite executive
founder entrepreneur needs to leave only
the paranoid survive if you're listening
to this and you're not in a state called
california or new york or oregon or
whatever else you want to call it and
you're in a place like texas or florida
like oh thank god i live in florida do
not be naive are they coming for you boy
do not be naive
this is the war of getting people to
think in a certain way and they are not
slowing down they're going to come after
you the other day i was watching a video
of a mother on david harris's instagram
page this mother was sharing textbooks
of his kids reading these books at 12
years old and i don't know if you saw
that or not did you see that i don't
want to say it i don't want to say what
we're selling today the mayor i think
because of david harris to show you the
power of information yeah because of
david harris and his reach and you
shared it and a bunch of other
influential people shared it the mayor
went to the town hall called the judge
and said i've confirmed with the judge
that this is child pornography you will
be arrested and you can either resign
your board your board right now
so
this is again not to panic that's that's
what i'm saying
what i'm trying to say is stay paranoid
don't just sit there and say go home
tonight and say babe thank god we're
living in a place like this nope that's
not how i'm wired i still ask the
questions you still got to ask the
question whatever your kids are going to
ask the question what do they talk about
in school today what i talked about in
school today all of a sudden your kid
brings an argument home to you who
brought that up to you my teacher what
did they say they said the president is
this they say that white people are this
they said that you know rich people are
this who said that what makes you
believe that go to school talk to the
teacher about it don't sit around and
say it's not a big deal babe just let it
go it's not a big deal yet let it go how
many times have you heard the story of a
father saying you know my chest hurts
you know my chest hurts you know my
chest hurts it's not a big deal it's not
a big deal it's not a big deal it's not
a big deal six months later it's a big
deal has a heart attack the man dies
your chest was hurting go to the
flipping doctor you could have prevented
that with a blood thinner you could have
lived 30 more years but we lost you we
don't get those memories for you to go
walk your daughter down the aisle stop
acting as if it cannot happen to you
everything is about you not being naive
thinking this cannot happen to your
county to your city to your community to
your state
you have to stay as
active as possible in gathering
information read as much as you can both
sides don't be naive if you do that part
you'll have the highest shot and by the
way i'll say i'll go a little bit even
further than that here's what i will
tell you
um
gary kasparov was at the event two weeks
ago okay
and i'm talking to gary and i said gary
you called that putin in 2008.
do you have any political aspirations no
no no i don't want to do any politics i
don't want to go into politics so what
are you talking about do you remember
when i'm like what are you talking about
backstage yeah what are you talking
about part of this was on stage he says
i tweet i said what do you mean you're
not going to go wrong for politics no no
i don't want to go to po i said no you
got to go
you got to do something you can't just
be sitting here writing stuff you have a
story that you can actu look at what
david harris is doing with his stuff he
flips there are people that are flipping
today even jpc is the comedian he's
getting people to think because the
approach is taken the guy is very
important today jp sears is very
necessary today who's the most necessary
person in america today who's the most
and necessary the number one most
necessary person in america today dave
chappelle it's it's a guy named joe
rogan
there isn't anybody in america today
most necessary than joe rogan
joe has got the same status thank god
they still haven't come after him to say
he's done something oh they've tried i
understand but he's got such a loyal
following that the people will go after
them
so some people who have never had any
aspirations
for politics i think it's time yeah some
people have never had any desires to
want to go do anything and you kind of
seen some of the stuff that's really
brewing in you and it's firing you up do
not waste that fire
do something with it yeah it may be a
five-year plan and maybe a 10-year plan
and maybe a 15-year plan or maybe a
20-year plan but it's time to get the
bench deep because the next 10 20 30 40
years we're going to need some true
solid true believers
real quick because uh sorry but to his
point i have the perfect example that
when i was working in the state house in
jersey there was a nun all right and it
does you don't have to run the whole
reason i'm saying this is that he's so
right you don't have to run you don't
even have to donate you just have to be
loud there was a nun who said there
people were drag racing down the block
okay down the block she called the state
house every single day when can we get a
speed bump okay i'll call back tomorrow
when can we get a speed bump one woman
one woman all right she called for like
32 straight days and then finally my
boss gene ashmore was like my god
almighty somebody just gave this lady a
freaking speedboat yeah she got the
speed bump yeah she got the speed bump
that one lady making a phone call every
day
she spoke for an entire community and
got it done and i'll validate one other
thing that pat said that if you think
you live in south dakota texas florida
idaho one of these states where you
think you're safe they're coming for
your school
all right they're infiltrating the core
of the apple right so they can get these
kids now and they're patient so don't
think it's not happening in your state
and in your state
you were in dallas go to deep ellum did
it feel like you were in when did it
feel like you were in texas no red tech
no go to houston does it feel like you
were in red tape interviewed a lot of
people in ebor city in florida eblor
city could be brooklyn new york pat let
me pose a question for you and and i
know you want to end there uh you know
the next five ten minutes so i wanna
throw something your way and this is a
question maybe a suggestion the audience
and then maybe something that advice to
people
do would you say that our channel is
built more for employers
or employees
free thinkers is number one okay
um but we are a capitalist
channel
we do encourage entrepreneurs
entrepreneur or entrepreneurs so to me
it's yes entrepreneurs independent free
thinkers that are constantly figuring
out ways to do something better all
right i would say that's the basis yeah
but capitalism is the basis yes awesome
we're on the same page here are there
more employers
in the country or more employees not
even close what's the number i would say
it's 20 to 1. 20 to 1. oh yeah there's
more employees no questions are more
employers
likely to be republicans or democrats
employers business owners employees or
yours
he's going with bell curve okay so you
got probably conservative yes okay not a
republican and more employees i don't
think i don't think it's republican okay
i think it's capitalist employers will
be capitalists but you could be a
democratic capitalist would you sure are
you willing to say that employers
employees
maybe they have a similar mission but a
different maybe agenda or an outlook
okay is that fair to say i'm not sure
where you're going okay
the point is this i think if you're an
employer
and you run a business yeah and you're
that guy like to use your story pat
that's just doing his business and doing
his thing you're in california and the
tax man shows up and says 80 g's pat pay
up
it's a pretty tough pill to swallow
that's never happened to me
running a business that hasn't happened
okay
an employee maybe doesn't ever have to
deal with something like that so what's
what's my point bingo
um
employers should try to have
conversations with employees and say
here's why i vote this way here's why i
have this perspective i'm not talking
about we do that
i know you do but this is my advice to
everyone else out there here's what
happens if i have to pay more in taxes
or if the corporate tax rates go up i'm
going to have to lay six of you guys off
and then an employee might say oh [ __ ] i
don't want right feedback by the way and
then employees is a great point thank
you and then employees
this guy and then apparently i'm
actually being serious that's a great
point thank you
and then employees
might want to
ask their employers yeah hey i noticed
that you're a big trump guy or you're a
big leave me a hell alone guy or you're
a big low-tech why why yeah
i think that's an important conversation
we get so caught up on these little
political things and and this and that
let's not forget here circling back
gavin newsom beat the [ __ ] out of his
competition two out of three people in
california said i don't know
you're right yeah yeah
so rather than saying
i think you just got to talk to the
people that have different opinions
that's all i'm saying inadvertently you
just made george carlin's argument
against democracy think about the most
average
intellect you know the most average
person you know and then understand that
half of the population is dumber than
that right think of the most average
wealth person you know the most most
average person you know
half the population is dumber than that
pro part of the problem with democracy
part of the problem representative
democracy
is that there is a very small percentage
of intelligent people in the world and
an even smaller percentage of
intelligent people that can convert that
into any sort of considerable wealth
yeah and you can't have a conversation
about politics with your employer it's
impossible i didn't say politics again
i'm saying
tell me about the taxes taxes aren't
those have to be political what happens
if the taxes go up but listen three of
you guys get fired you gotta understand
what's the alternative not talking to
each other that makes no sense to me but
what does it matter okay all this
doesn't matter if it gets to a place
where the the system is too rigged
against choice even two choices if they
get 3.5 trillion dollars that goes all
to their people and all to their
political donations then like pat said
half of the business sector that may not
agree with it they have to get on board
because that's the only way you're going
to survive you may say hey look i hate
these taxes but if the only way as a
construction guy i'm getting any money
is to get tax dollars guess where i'm
going so the the power politics the
power of politics becomes a leverage
game and you get really really really
close when you get outside that laffer
curve it becomes an exponential turn and
that's when things get really really i
think most people are because you're
either in the party or you're out of the
party i think we have the luxury of
sitting here debating politics and
nuance i don't think most people do this
i think most people just wake up and say
it's the famous powerful line you know
what that line is what it is never talk
about religion and business and religion
and politics and business
such a it's such a
it's such a manipulative line
it's such a anybody i've ever met that
is extremely intelligent
or uh a reader
anybody i've met their favorite things
to talk about or debate is have to have
the philosophies it's the philosophy
religion politics it's like some of
course sports is a part of it that's fun
yeah but those are things i want to tell
what do you think about this gosh [ __ ]
here we go right i mean i'm talking of
you know somebody having a conversation
it's very common by the way we got eight
minutes to do and does anybody have any
opinion on general milly do we want to
cover that yeah sure okay so let's go
through it since we got eight minutes
left so
general milley feared trump might launch
nuclear attack made secret calls to
china new book says usa today in the
aftermath of january 6 attack on the u.s
capitol joint chief of staff chairman
general mark milley then the former
president trump's top military adviser
took precautions to limit trump's
ability to launch a military strike or
deploy nuclear weapons according to a
new book by bob woodward who's always
talking about this stuff and robert
costa the washington post in a rare move
millie called the secret meeting of
senior military officials at the
pentagon on january to review the
process of military action including
launching nuclear weapons he instructed
those in charge of the national military
commander center the pentagon's war room
not to take orders from anyone without
his involvement
mili also reassured uh chinese general
lee zhu cheng of the people's
libertarian army that the u.s had no
intention of launching an airstrike
against china it was one of two secret
phone calls shared by lee on the issue
zenner thoughts you know it just goes to
uh gerard's point that uh think of the
average intelligence person you know and
assume that 50 of the people are dumber
than that if you believe this crap
you're an idiot you're a flat out idiot
if you think donald trump was thinking
of a nuclear war on january 6. who the
hell was he going to attack new jersey i
mean who would be in the crosshairs of
our of an attack you know it's one thing
if you don't like him but you don't have
to you know paint him as a buffoon or
someone that would launch a nuclear
weapon on his final week in office
meanwhile eric swalwell from california
actually threatened nukes against the
american citizens yeah and you know it's
just so blatantly obvious that this is
an end run to take the attention off
afghanistan i mean you either have
common sense or you don't i'd like to
think i have a little bit and that's the
only way i see this story by the way
some people on the opposing side are
saying what an honorable thing to do
to take the responsible position to make
the phone call to prevent him from doing
what he did adam what are your thoughts
about this i i think um you can't have
it both ways because we have two stories
here on the list
one based on this book peril from uh bob
ward and robert costa and if you don't
know who robert costa is the guy is a
total g he sat down there he's
interviewed trump bob woodward
yes yeah correct
we all know woodward but you don't know
if you know costa yeah so they're
telling this story and then we have a
story on the other page where basically
they called out
biden about him calling out uh mansion
so do you either can you read that
actually read the story read the read
the part
biden told joe manchin to support his
1.9 trillion corona by a stimulus
because if you don't come along you're
really [ __ ] me the book says
that's what biden's system answers yes
okay so
you want me to keep going no no you can
go back to the point you were making the
point is this so
tom says he doesn't believe it all right
so do you believe this point though
you can't have you can't point at you
you can you can't
automatically assume everything he says
is true or false i choose to believe
that i don't think donald trump was
thinking of launching nuclear weapons on
january sure okay wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait we're both missing
are you saying you're thinking he was
about to launch i don't think so
i don't think he was about to talk about
it i do think that he was after the the
day he lost or after the january 6th
i do think to use some of the words that
they used he was angry okay erratic
emotional
potentially unstable and unpredictable
was he nuking people i don't think so
speaking of track record let's talk
about one predictable in this case means
not doing what we want him to do
because that if you want to look at the
parallels to your point if you want to
look at the parallels between the two
stories joe manchin is saying no i'm not
giving you three point five trillion
dollars
this was back in march because it's not
now so what i'm saying is that he's
still saying no
with all due respect we're getting stuck
in the minutia here this is the top
general in the united states of america
going behind an elected official duly
elected official going behind who
represents the citizens
he had just lost like but he didn't
leave office he was still a prisoner he
was the president united states and this
guy's calling our number one if you
don't want to use the word enemy our
number one competitor on the world scale
behind the back